hello and welcome to this video playing
empires and he's playing the Dutch yeah
against this and d3 and d4 is
interesting but I'm never really am not
really a fan honest I'm just going to
stick to two regular anti Dutch
procedures yeah I know before looks a
bit funky maybe the move water but I'm
going to play a C for D for just a
little bit later so and before is not a
bad move on in that regard so here maybe
five I'm not really a very knowledgeable
hear about the new orders I know that
this setup would be form C for D form is
quite good but I'm not very well
informed about blacks some various
responses something like e five takes
Knight g4 as always some on the radar
problem Queen b3 is correct yeah yeah do
we go b5 now or a3 a3 as the slope
that's gonna be five a drawback of this
move is that okay then after some p5 and
I take that he has a c5 potentially
[Music]
I would like to cover the b2 bishop
Queen b3 for example but then there's a
form it's quite annoying
maybe I'll go here not certain him but I
want you're making five more difficult
maybe nine to be g7 and prepare in five
I can store me if he goes e5 I can still
capture and play c5 I'm not totally
certain that this is good but I also
have I have Bishop e3 which probably
wins the exchange but it's going to be
risky I'm still tough to not to not take
this material I mean the rook has no
squares just f7 and then Knight g5 picks
up the exchange it's it's only that my
dark squares are already weakened with
this b5 construction giving him the c5
square and can easily be that he's
getting getting very good very good
plane yeah and we already see a problem
him he might just have quickly five I
don't know yeah I already said when I
when I went for them they went for this
win of the exchange that it's going to
be somewhat dies it is soon and
it certainly is he gets a lot of
compensation but it was I think it was
tough to not to not go for that I
[Music]
expected g5 but okay so maybe going for
95 is the correct way to do it I could
have tried to just return the exchange
that is that would have been an option
so here let's get get decentralized yeah
I don't mind if he takes it really
I wonder if night-night f4 is the
correct way to flame it's going to come
out as a should have seven I guess and
then he three at least I'm getting back
back with the knight to the center it
was really dreadful on age three and
again I don't mind if he let's say G 592
and if he takes on d5 winds that power
I'm not I'll help you down we should
take spawn takes Queen d5 and move the
rope and it's it's it's fine yeah here
Knight b6 probably just and take once
Knight b6
going back to didn't really work some
okay ready yeah I'm quite ready now for
nights deform we cannot call 96 because
of 97 I think getting in 94 would be
very desirable the night was on h3
just some months ago yeah I think I'm
okay yeah really should be a good
position okay ID force attacking f5 and
that I have to take it's just no way I'm
not taking it
Knoblauch is falling apart now
[Music]
you know there wasn't there wasn't all
that clear with this trying to grab the
exchange that was maybe not even good oh
I'm sorry I did not have my microphone I
now recognize that I hope this sound was
somewhat somewhat bearable so um
there should be two shares a little bit
strange so d4 he went a five year I
wondered yeah if he five takes an IG 4
is something the computer doesn't really
like it Queen b3 Knight e5 c5 yeah that
looks indeed quite good okay he went a
5v5 Queenie AIDS Quincy too not sure
yeah
as mentioned I am I would have liked to
play Queen to b3 but that runs into a
four and I wasn't sure this is the
engine recommendation if this is correct
damn but probably e5 isn't really an
option anyway I've got 95 which opens
this up and deserts and this now that is
very good Freud okay I don't think a
discrete issue is not a mistake I guess
and I've been here seven castles g5 yeah
and now I started to grab that material
and yeah we are probably it's probably
not that great so we should be 3e for I
am the engine likes black before I play
95 and now aged six I think this is
already giving him good compensation for
sure Knight e5 is also an engine
recommendation that also I mean makes
perfect sense
the issue is that it's just that rooks
currently my rooks are not really doing
much and he has minor pieces that are
very strong those three they're very
strong and mine idea
is stranded we'll have to go to age
three and then it is kind of offside I
hope I stopped them so I stopped this
out on time sorry for that yeah this is
some great compensation for black now
he's got age 65 and men night is bad
yeah it was still too tempting to grab
the material so the way it went it it
could led to this position and I was
thinking he should play some g5 soon
energy form maybe 93 and now the engine
gives c6 probably because 95 is such an
annoying idea so the engine
recommendation is c6 route could be one
yeah maybe
and then g5 now you need to you need
this and make this a night look bad the
computer gives white a very small
advantage in a practical game blacks
position is completely fine I think I'm
not sure what I would to take probably I
would rather take black because you know
what you watch it you have to do play on
the kingside on the other hand I also
know with white what you do have to play
here and try to trade down attacking
pieces
he played Queen to e5 which allowed this
95 move and yeah I was feeling quite
happy when this Knight comes back into
the game and now after e3 I'm assured of
this Square and yeah from here on I
think it is quite quite a substantial
advantage already
five young Queen c7 and after 94 it's
basically over yeah that was interesting
I think here black has quite decent play
for the exchange probably if we go back
to this 93 s a lot better it seems then
my Quincey to move if the if this grab
of the exchange is not good then I have
to reconsider if I want to take only
five in the first place actually I mean
I took it with the idea of grabbing the
material other than that taking only
five is not yeah not very great I
probably would have gone III then if I
just yeah if this option of grabbing
material is not there but black is
probably probably fine him maybe maybe I
get the Sun but he could play v6 make it
at least more difficult for those most
but he has he always has some ideas on
the Cyril board okay guys thanks for
watching